so the way I think about industry events
are I wanted to use these events as an
opportunity to meet potential users so
when I was just starting out I was
looking to meet people who are into
sharing so I went to meet ups that are
around recycling and sharing and things
like that just so I could talk to people
and tell them hey look this is what I
want to build what do you think about it
would you use something like that and
those have been really really useful the
other type of industry events are just
those events where you go to mingle and
meet you know other entrepreneurs and
investors and just kind of network I
I've done I've I went to some of those i
have to say that like after attending a
few I just completely stopped going and
realized that this is not my way to
network and I should be getting work
done and getting the traction with my
product and then meet the right people
who see you know that this is working
and it's interesting for them in order
to get noticed in events or anywhere if
you're networking you need to do
something that people care about people
who would want to interact with so even
if it's a very serious trade show with a
lot of people with the suits that are
looking for specific things if you're
going to be fun and an open and engaging
people are going to notice you I saw
people walking around with comedians
that are giving them if you talk with me
I'll tell you a joke oh we're doing
paintball party later oh we're offering
a yoga class in the morning do you want
to sign up some stuff like that that
people are not expecting to get in
conferences people are not expecting to
get in in those places this can really
make a change